[Music]
ha no you took just love us and my
friends this is guns in here welcome to
the 30th episode of dirty chest tricks
now if you are dragon or exited dragon
player the good news is in this video I
am going to show you one of my pet
tricky line which not only contains a
lot of tricks but important point is
there is hardly any theory on this line
so occasionally you can use this in a
professional tournament as a complete
surprise weapon the Sicilian Hungarian
variation arises after the following
model
efore c5 Knight to f3 d6 d4 C captures
d4 Knight captures d4 and as I have
highlighted over here the major choice
of the black is to play Knight to c6 or
Bishop to g7 however we are going to
play this surprising move Knight to f6
the good point about 9 to f6 is it
straight away attacking on e4 so it
completely stopped some of the annoying
system by wide such as marcozzi bind
with c4 white also doesn't want to play
f3 because it will completely weaken
this G 1 to e 7 diagonally for the
beginners you should know that I can
never push this pawn because of the
simple Queen check and within the 5th
move of the game black wins upon so more
or less here what is forced to play
Knight to c3 and if black continue with
d6 then will be transposed to the
mainline dragon but once again we are
going to continue with our surprising
opening Bishop to g7
now the only drawback you can say of
this line is if white is careful enough
then at this position he can play the
movie phi and then black has nothing
better to play Knight to g8 however it
was still transposed to the Kasparov
Edition and I have attached a sample
line in the PGA wear black obtain a
decent equality so far I have played
this line in more than 50 games and
Aoife has been occurred only three times
what I found out is many white players
routinely turn out this main line move
such as Bishop to e3 because they don't
want to involve in other lines and they
are relying on their own theory ok
black is going to Castle now and if
white is not careful enough then black
will achieve his traumatic break defy
and get a clear-cut equalizer at this
position Aoife is not good either
because after ePHI Knight to e8 f4 d6
pawn takes and Knight takes only thing
White has done is weaken his white king
with the small F phone and later on
black can easily target those squares
if you check this position in online
database you will find out that the
highest Lee played move in this position
is Bishop to c4 and it's logical as well
it's one of the mainline move in many
Sicilian lines because it's completely
stopped the defy idea by black and yes
indeed it's true except there is big
difference that black hasn't committed
Knight to c6 and that allowed this
wonderful ploy in the opening BAM
so just because black hasn't committed
Knight to c6 black can execute this
technical idea and we are about to see
more fun in this line now else I have
highlighted over here white has two
choices but amongst them Bishop captures
epsilon is a versed one
because after rook captures f7 and
Knight captures efore White has given up
the bishop pair and in the long run
white is going to pay for this to give
you a brief idea how comfortable black
position is I raise this position
against a 2,000 rated opponent where I
continue with Knight to c6 pressurizing
the d4 square my opponent continued with
logical might to g5 attacking the rook I
first of all played Queen check and
after Bishop to d2 Queen to e5 happen so
now black is attacking to sports so
white responds his force white has to
play Knight to e2 but there comes Luke
to a fire once again attacking two spots
and after the following continuation
that is Bishop to c3 Queen to B Phi
Bishop captures g7 King kept his g7
Knight to f3 and Queen captures b2
within the 15 moves of the game black is
a healthy pawn up and white has hardly
any compensation for it
the more frequent response here is night
captious efore which is very logical
white is saying that okay you can have
your piece back but then I'll get my
pawn back and we are equal right well
it's not that simple because of course
black is going to play the moon defy and
now here white has three choices
first of all Bishop captures defy is not
a good option the simple reason is after
Queen captures defy we are checking the
night the night cannot move as G to pawn
will drop so by force white has to play
the move f3 and after that we are going
to continue with our normal piece
development such as Knight to c6 and
apart from obtaining the bishop pair
White has some talk Square weaknesses
which can be easily exploited later part
of the middle game the most obvious
choice from the white is to play Bishop
to d3 and after black recapture the
piece White recapture his pawn and
arguing that what you have achieved well
here comes the whole point you are about
to witness a very beautiful trick just
in the opening which will completely
finish your opponent now before I show
it to you I like you to pause this video
and find out what is the continuation
which gives black a completely upper
hand
did you find it let's see the winning
combo start with a very obvious move fi
White has two choices first Knight to e6
is not good the simple reason is after
Bishop capture c6 Queen captures Queen
rook captures Queen and now obviously
white can take the rook in the corner
with Bishop captures b7 but the bottom
line is after Bishop captures b2 rook to
Devon Knight to d7 Bishop captures eight
and rook captures eight black emerged
with a two minor piece against rook
which always gives black a decisive
advantage I have attached a sample line
in the PG in which will guide you how
black can execute his winning plan I did
this position in more than 25 games and
probably 90% of my opponent has played
the move Bishop to b3 thinking that
there is nothing going on in this
position but here comes the super shock
boom so now we are dislodging the bishop
which is supporting the night and still
white is not losing a piece but trust me
it's not easy to see how white can
retain his piece many of my opponent has
just given up a piece and I had quickly
finished the game but the most critical
line is here white can't play Bishop to
c4 giving a check and after King to h8
White has this good move Knight to b5
which in fact never has been played by
any of my opponent anyways we still need
to see how black get an advantageous
position if your opponent continued with
this line here black should continue
with F captures III Queen captures Queen
rook captures Queen and now Knight to c7
the obvious grabbing the rook in the
corner policy but here it's come
different than last variation because
now we can play pawn captures f7 giving
a check if King to have fun then rook to
d2 is a very strong reply and that pawn
is a nuisance in the white cam so more
or less White has to take this pawn and
after that we are going to give this
check again and it doesn't matter
wherever King goes he will get a
sequence of checks for example one game
against a feed a master continue it King
- even Bishop captures be to look to be
one Bishop to c3 check King to e2 fish
up to g4 check if King to e3 then look
to see it is very strong reply so white
played here King to d3 attacking the
bishop but after Bishop to f6 Knight
captures eight night to seven attacking
the knight white obviously tried to save
the night with Knight to g7 but that
comes look to see hit lining up against
two pieces and by force black is going
to get one of them in the game night to
defy happen but after Knight check King
to d2 and night kept a c4 check after
the whole sequence black obtain a to
Bishop and upon against rook which is
always going to be a decisive winning
factor for the black camp
at this position the third option night
to be fire probably the strongest and
suggested by the engine but as a human
if you are facing this position first
time I don't think so
hardly any of your opponent are going to
turn out this move anyways we need to
see how we are going to build with this
line and my recommendation is you
continue with Asics so white has few
pieces hanging but White's idea is he
wants to play Queen captures defy and
here black responds his force black has
to capture the knight on the B Phi
square if Queen captures B Phi then
Bishop to d7 is a very strong reply and
I have attached a sample line in the PGN
but in one online game my 2100 rated
opponent continued with castle on the
Queen side which is in fact one of the
stronger in this position but I calmly
continue with Quint we file so now
indeed black is attacking this bishop
any Bishop to b3 then Bishop to e6 is a
very strong reply so my opponent grabbed
the be Phi pawn I exchange the Queen and
the net result is I got the a to pawn
and attack on b2 beyond so my opponent
has to forcefully continue with c3 but
there comes Bishop to a5 attacking the
knight f3 defending and now comes Roop
to c8 and we don't need to go further
you can easily see that black has to
raking bishop along with this deadly
rooks and if anyone has a winning
chances in this position is only black
due to his tremendous piece activity
well I hope with this mini lecture on
the Sicilian Hungarian variation you are
now confident enough to use this line as
a surprise weapon in your professional
tournament remember that plane I kept to
c4 shock your opponent and get the full
point as quickly as possible thank you
for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on this video and I'll meet you in my
next episode very soon bye and take care